hey guys I'm Abbey shark welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's what I eat in a
day youtuber review is sponsored by
audible and we're gonna be looking at
John glod from the YouTube channel obese
to beast now before we dive in I want to
tell you about this awesome app called
audible that I've been using before bed
and on my daily walks now audible is a
leading provider for spoken word
entertainment and audiobooks where you
can download your favorite books and
listen anytime anywhere I have been
listening to Gary bishops go on F
yourself which has really helped me get
through some of these really uncertain
times we're in but it's all about
getting rid of the negative self-talk in
your life that's holding you back from
truly thriving and it does so with some
really great sassy language that I can
definitely get on board with anyway the
way it works is that every month you get
one credit for any title plus two
audible originals from the monthly
selections and access to daily news and
meditations so key you also get to keep
your audiobook library even if you
cancel and you can participate in
audiobook exchanges so if you're looking
for some affordable entertainment you
can check out audible.com slash Abby
sharp or text Abby sharp - 500 500 and
start listening with an exclusive 30-day
free trial one free audiobook and two
audible originals for free okay
so let's talk about our friend John now
if you're unfamiliar with obese two
beasts channel he's a fitness and
wellness youtuber who's gained
popularity by documenting his extreme
weight loss through CrossFit training
and following what he's coined as the
common sense diet which according to him
means he's eliminated all fast-food soda
and snacking from his diet now before we
get too far into this I want to start
with my general disclaimer that the
information that you may see in this
video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only and you should
always seek out the help of a registered
dietician or medical professional for
your unique case all right let's meet
John so I just kind of wanted to share
what I've been eating in a day and I
want to make it very clear from the star
this video this is me just sharing what
I'm eating I'm not at all trying to say
you need to eat what I what I eat at all
most people probably wouldn't want to
eat what I eat because it's very boring
but I wanted to share that because I
want people to see that like for me when
I think about you know eating and the
way that I think about food is I want my
food to be one very simple and to
something that I can sustain for a long
time right so it's nothing super fancy
okay so if you've been watching me for a
while you've probably already picked up
on the fact that I always appreciate a
good disclaimer from these YouTube
videos so thank you to John for pressing
this video with a disclaimer and stating
that the purpose is really to share what
he eats as a kind of FYI I also love
that he says his eating is really rooted
in simplicity and sustainability which
is definitely something I can totally
agree with I mean I think that the
easier you can make healthy eating the
more likely you are to stick to it let's
see what else he has to say now I do
want to say before I show you everything
that I got that was actually talking
about this recently on my podcast did I
understand about everything that you're
gonna see is not less I'm like super
healthy like whoa that's such a can't
believe a healthy that he eats and stuff
like that that's not what at all what
I'm trying to show you I actually think
that my diet is actually pretty normal I
think that it's pretty sustainable for
pretty much anybody so again I'm not
saying that this is what you should be
eating but I understand it's not the
pinnacle of health and fitness but it
works really well for me and coming from
someone that had a little bit of
disordered eating obviously through
fruit food addiction then binge eating
and then struggling with a little bit of
orthorexia like I don't feel like I need
to eat perfectly healthy to still be
able to chase my goals okay so in this
other video on his grocery haul I love
that John talks about how this diet is
normal and balanced and not just like
whoa super healthy he mentions that he
has a history of food addiction and
binge eating and orthorexia and is now
in a place where his focus is not
necessarily on eating perfectly healthy
but rather to eat a diet that is normal
and sustainable for him while still
making progress in the gym and reaching
his goals I am very relieved
to hear this coming from John as
research has shown that rates of
disordered eating are very common
amongst athletes in weight class sports
so you can have health goals even
physique goals without letting them run
your life okay now let's get into the
diet and look at day one
[Music]
okay so I can definitely see where John
gets his beasts nickname this definitely
looks like a tough workout so let's see
what he's gonna eat it's about 10:30
I'm about to have my first I don't
really call this a meal but my first
thing of the day I've really been liking
these cliff builders bars not sponsored
or anything like that but I like them
because there's no way protein in them
but they have relatively okay macros so
we are back home now it is like 1
o'clock normally I don't eat this late
this usually I don't wait this long eat
my first meal but because of the couple
things that came up I just decided to
push the food back a little bit so this
is what I've been having for my first
meal for the past couple weeks now that
it's hotter it's been like a chicken
salad a regular salad and then like
fruits normally like an apples let me
show you this
[Music]
so I'll be the first to say that this is
far from an impressive meal so we got
the Apple we got the sandwich with the
chicken salad in it and then there's the
rest of the chicken salad in there and
then I have half of that salad in this
top layer so it looks like John is
already having a busy day and it's 10:30
but I am happy to see that he still has
time to sneak some nutrition in for
post-workout recovery now an ideal
post-workout recovery snack would
include a combination of protein and
carbohydrates to help rebuild muscle and
replenish energy stores though the cliff
builders protein bars that John eats
after his workout does have protein and
carbohydrate considering the intensity
of his workout you know he may want to
ideally aim for around one gram of
protein for every 3 to 4 grams of
carbohydrates like he mentions the cliff
builders bar provides about 20 grams of
protein and 30 grams of carbs so it is a
pretty good choice in the grand scheme
of things but he could definitely easily
optimize it with like a piece of fruit
like an apple or a banana as for his
lunch
I guess we'll call it or I don't know
the first meal of his day I love that
we're keeping it real here to say that
most people even youtubers don't
necessarily make beautifully styled
lunches every single day and eat them on
wooden Photography boards this is real
life and it looks pretty good to me I
actually love that particular bag salad
myself with the poppy seed dressing for
days that I'm in a pinch but we've got
some protein from the chicken carved
from the Apple and dried fruit fat from
the dressing and the seeds some nice
dark greens from the kale slaw it's good
stuff he also mentions that even though
his meal is not impressive it's
something that he genuinely truly enjoys
eating honestly I think that the
simplest less impressive meals actually
tend to be the most satisfying anyways
and at the end of the day if you enjoy
what you're eating that is all that
really matters to me let's look at dig
to see we got it right here so we have 3
whole eggs 3 egg whites and then we also
have bell pepper and spinach on that we
have a bunch of mixed berries
300 grams of berries we have
strawberries raspberries blackberries
and blueberries in this then we have two
pieces of bread with peanut butter on it
the reason that I did the peanut butter
on the bread is because I do the three
eggs and that's a little bit of fat it's
not too much but I like I definitely
wanted to have more fat so I add the
peanut butter I've really been liking
this this meal or like trying something
different because one I'm trying to add
more like fruits and vegetables all
throughout the day just because it's
just something personally that I've been
wanting to do and two it's less of like
just the straight carbs that I was
getting from the oatmeal because the
openeth at I wouldI in the morning
normally was like a hundred and twenty
grams of oats so that's quite a bit of
carbs plus I would put some sort of like
bar normally crumble that up in there so
that meal would always end up being
probably my biggest meal of the day at
about a thousand to 1,200 calories and
this is a little bit less calories and I
don't feel as sluggish now I don't know
if I'll never go back to eating oats in
the morning but this is a has been a
nice change and it's really good okay so
it is great to see that John is really
listening to his body and trying
something new for breakfast by switching
up his protein with the eggs instead of
having oats and adding in some more
fruits and veggies to his diet I think
we're all susceptible to following into
kind of breakfast ruts and I think it's
really common for people in the fitness
community to just become accustomed to
eating the exact same meal every single
morning I get that it's definitely
easier because you don't have to think
about calculating the macros as I can
see he definitely has done with this but
I would definitely try to encourage John
to have maybe like two or three
different meals that he rotates just to
get some greater variety of nutrition
into his day having said that as far as
balance goes this looks really great to
me for a breakfast I love that we've got
protein from the eggs we've got fat from
the nut butter and yolks carved from the
fruit and the bread plus there's some
extra veggies snuck in there looks
really satisfying and probably a better
choice after a big workout compared to
what he described having before which
was just oats with a little bit of a bar
on top
the extra fat in there may slow down
carbohydrate and and protein absorption
a little bit but if it's working for
John it's working for me because I just
love how balanced it is in general let's
see what else he has this cliff
builder's bar right here I really like
these you guys know I don't do dairy
messes with my stomach gives me mad acne
but these are these are nice they get a
good amount of calories in because again
for me not trying to lose weight or
anything like that okay so we just found
out that John doesn't consume dairy
because he says it causes some digestive
discomfort and acne so let's just unpack
that for a quick second research has
shown that dairy can cause breakouts in
some people especially those with more
acne prone skin it also sounds like John
may or may not be lactose intolerant if
it's causing some serious stomach upset
or at the very least he's finding way to
cause bloating which is not uncommon
research has shown that some people
report difficulty digesting whey protein
and experienced digestive symptoms like
bloating gas stomach cramps and diarrhea
these digestive symptoms are usually
related to lactose intolerance as
lactose is the main carbohydrate in whey
protein so for people who experience
lactose intolerance and are looking for
an appropriate protein powder whey
protein isolate would be a more
appropriate option versus whey protein
concentrate as the isolate has a smaller
amount of lactose other non-dairy
protein powder options include soy pee
rice or hemp protein so if you're also
finding yourself bloated after way maybe
experiment with some other proteins to
find the best one for you
on another note it's also really
refreshing to see somebody in the weight
loss community look at the calories on
the nutrition labels to ensure that
they're getting enough calories versus
looking for a lower amount although John
is known for his extreme weight loss I
get the impression that his goals are
now to really build and maintain muscle
mass while maintaining a sustainable
balanced diet and he knows that any
extreme
caloric restriction isn't gonna help him
out there let's take a look at meal 2 we
got some overnight oats that I made last
night
they have a 120 grams of oats we have a
serving of this Skippy peanut butter
have some sweetener I like to use sweet
and low also we have this new ghost
protein this is the vegan pancake batter
I went to GNC I bought this and the last
thing I do is I crunch up one of these
little nut bars and I put this in the
oats
okay so again we have a super simple
meal here with the overnight oats which
is admittedly one of my favorite no-fuss
meals of all time I love that we have
some healthy complex carbohydrates from
the oats tons of protein with the
protein powder and healthy fats from the
peanut butter and crushed nut bar on top
I mean I would love a little veg in
there but that would probably be kind of
strange in oats and he did have a salad
this day for the first meal proving that
breakfast does not have to mean cereal
and lunch does not need to mean salad
there is no nutrition rule book that
says your body needs to necessarily get
these stereotypical meals in a
particular order so I love that John is
switching things up let's take a look at
day twos second meal so for the macros
so for one serving at 60 calories one
fat three carbs and eight grams of
protein so we're gonna be adding 16
grams of protein because I'm going to do
two servings in this we have two little
pieces of toast with some berries on it
and then I just threw some berries and
the rest of the whatever pudding protein
pudding I guess if you want to call it
so this will be a fun meal I mean
honestly this is not something that I
eat all of the time this is actually my
first time like mixing the powder with
this exact pudding so we'll see how it
tastes I guess I'll do a little live
taste test haven't done that no forever
okay so with this meal John is getting
ready for his second workout of the day
and he's created his protein pudding
concoction with some dairy free yogurt
and protein cookie butter and then threw
it on some toast mmm this guy gets some
serious creativity points right here
because of this I can only imagine how
delicious that taste
but I also love putting yogurt on toast
instead of like cream cheese and I often
makes a little powdered peanut butter in
mine so I guess it's basically like the
same idea and I love it
also though cookie butter protein yes
please
so I love that he is staying true to
mandate of adding more fruit to his diet
by topping it off with berries so kudos
to you John it also makes sense that he
would want to limit his fat intake prior
to a workout and focus more on protein
and carbs as fat will slow down the rate
of digestion which may leave him feeling
a little bit sluggish and bloated before
his workout I also want to quickly
address the fact that I see him weighing
and measuring his food a lot first of
all I want to acknowledge how common and
normalized this behavior is in the
fitness community as a lot of fitness
enthusiasts may aim for very specific
macronutrient ranges but considering
John's orth Rexach past I do wonder if
measuring and weighing his food is it
all triggering to him as this may
perpetuate disordered thoughts and
behaviors it may not be an issue for him
anymore but I'm just flagging this
because it can be hard for a lot of
people to just turn off those thoughts
let's take a look at how his afternoon
looks before getting into meal 3 say
4:30 now and I'm getting ready to go to
the gym for workout number 2 this is
going to be more my bodybuilding focused
workout so today we have a push workout
so it was gonna be mainly chest and
shoulders but I'm actually about to head
out again and go on a lot I've been
trying to add in a walk ok so far John
had a pretty hardcore workout this
morning then he had a second workout at
4:30 and immediately after it went on a
long walk now I wish I had that kind of
time of my day that was kind of my dream
I mean maybe I'm not doing anything
strenuous like that but I would also
love to do like a little weights in the
morning Pilates in the afternoon nice
little walk with friends when of course
social distancing becomes a thing of the
past but with a busy toddler a busy
business and another baby on the way
that's gonna have to wait until like
retirement for me but I mean kudos to
him this
is clearly a huge priority for him in
his life and I mean what a blessing now
going by his timestamps it's been about
four and a half hours since his last
meal and ideally you'd probably would
want to space your meals and snacks
around two to three hours apart to keep
your blood sugar levels balanced and to
ensure that you're getting enough energy
throughout the day especially for that
level of activity but for someone like
John who is really physically active
it's ideal to eat shortly after working
out like we talked about before that
combination of carbs and protein and
actually if we're getting technical you
know some would suggest around three
times as many carbs as protein but there
is no fuel between his afternoon workout
and his walk and nothing going in for at
least like three and a half hours after
the gym which is less than ideal
honestly it really wouldn't be a big
deal for like a really recreational gym
goer but because this is clearly really
important to him I would think he would
want to optimize that time he's spending
in the gym so let's see what kind of
impact this has on his dinner and I'm
about to make dinner but I got kind of
hungry so I'm gonna eat another Apple
and then I'm gonna finish off that salad
that I made earlier in the day and then
I'm going to make dinner dinner is made
as you guys saw so it's just stir-fry
we got like 200 grams of rice in there
as well it's just the Uncle Ben's it's
super easy it's pretty good it's not bad
I normally just use the orange chicken
sauce that Panda Express makes but it's
kinda nice to change it up a little bit
so this is dinner I'm very excited to
eat this okay so I'm not entirely
surprised that John is too famished
to just go in and cook his dinner before
needing to eat his leftovers and the
Apple from earlier on in the day I mean
I imagine he must be like hangry at this
point I know I definitely would be after
working out and then walking especially
since it's been like five and a half
hours since he ate and he's done a gym
workout and cardio after that his blood
sugar levels are likely pretty low at
this point
not only because he waited so long
between
but also because he expended so much
energy within this period of time
through intense physical activity again
John could have easily curbed this by
having like a snack shortly after his
second workout something like a protein
bar or like a little protein smoothie a
piece of toast with tuna something like
that I mean there are lots of really
fast easy options that he could have
even taken a smoothie with him on the
walk as for his dinner
John is nothing if not consistent again
we are seeing a really super simple
pretty balanced nutrient dense meal he's
made things really quick and easy by
using Uncle Ben's microwavable rice as
well as using pre-cut frozen vegetables
and what looks like precooked frozen
chicken slices as well that's already
been kind of pre measured out though
John's meal is balanced with protein
carbs and veggies I would have liked to
see some healthy fats in there to really
boost up the nutrition and help him get
the most out of those fat soluble
vitamins so maybe like a little drizzle
of sesame oil or topping his bowl off
with some cashew nuts or sesame seeds
again I assumed this was a deliberate
choice based on his desired macros but
if we're talking general balanced diet
this would be my recommendation I would
also say out--we rather see the fats
happening around this time of the day
rather than after the first workout just
to help with protein and and glucose
absorption having said that if we're
still in like social isolation by the
time this video comes out then this
would be a great easy meal option for
those who hate cooking I am a huge fan
of stir fries in general because you can
easily change up the protein grains
veggies and sauce and make it a
completely different meal every night of
the week simple
maybe not crazy inventive but good by me
let's take a look at day two all right
so it is dinner time and I'm sure to no
one's surprise we're making stir-fry
here
and we're back with another stir-fry
okay so even though John has switched
things up a little bit and added some
more variety to his meals in general the
tried-and-true stir-fry remains his
favorite dinner meal which he claims to
eat almost every day and you know what
that is totally okay I mean if it works
for him and it's something he
consistently enjoys every single time
then why the heck not I mean if it ain't
broke don't fix it the one thing I do
want to point out is that I noticed that
John tends to use cooking spray all the
time instead of any regular oil to
grease his pan whenever he cooks now I
don't know if this is for convenience
sake Organa fits to save calories and
fat macros but many people do try to
reduce calories in this way as cooking
sprays are believed to be a no calorie
option compared with regular high
calorie oil however this is not actually
the case
it can be a bit confusing to interpret
how many calories you're actually
getting from using a cooking spray as
the calories are measured per one third
of a second of a spray also if a portion
size has less than 0.5 grams of fat it
can be rounded down to zero grams and if
there's zero grams of fat apparently
that means there's zero calories per
serving this is why food manufacturers
make portion sizes so unrealistically
teeny-weeny in real life you're not
usually spraying for a fraction of a
second you're good to go to like fully
coat the pan and maybe you're reapplying
as you cook so I would say for most
people at 2 to 5 second spray perhaps is
actually far more realistic depending on
the size of your cooking pan and what
you're cooking so if there's about 2.25
calories in a third of a cooking spray
then if you spray for 5 seconds that's
34 calories worth of oil still really
negligible and even in a lot of cases
the distribution of oil can still help
you reduce your total intake compared to
adding like a big luck in the pan but I
just wanted to share that little wee
tidbit of information in case some of
you out there think that
nonstick spray is miraculously
calorie-free
let's take a look at some of his snacks
and I'm going to end the night with the
classic peanut butter jelly sandwich and
some almond milk so like I said in this
video this is nothing special and again
like I said I don't recommend that
people eat this this is just the way
that I like to eat dealing with like
people that are going to judge every
single meal that I've shown it just
makes you not want to show it that much
because again it's like I know I don't
make the best decisions at every single
moment of my life but at the same time
like I've been able to make progress
even though maybe the decisions aren't
the best okay so I totally see where
Jonah's coming from when he says he's
been apprehensive about doing his full
day of eating videos because he doesn't
want to deal with people judging what he
eats
maybe he's specifically talking about me
but like I said I I really do these
videos not to shame people for their
food choices but because anyone who's
putting content out there on the
internet about wellness and health and
diet has a lot of power to influence
other people's beliefs and behaviors we
have a huge responsibility even if we
say oh but you don't have to eat that
way as for John I like that his food
choices aren't the best all the time
whatever he means by that I actually
think his choices are really really
amazing and most importantly they're
definitely approachable like he said an
despite the online haters I do applaud
John for being real and just eating what
he likes regardless of whether or not
it's perfect eating doesn't ever have to
be perfect or fit into a certain type of
mold you know we really should not feel
the need to eat in a way to always
appease others so thank you John for
following the beat of your own drum and
eating in a way that makes you feel
satisfied now in response to a snack we
got a classic PB&J some almond milk
again I guess it was wrong on people
drinking this by the glass it is a real
thing so please do excuse my ignorance
on that but he
also mentions at the end that he had an
Rx bar in terms of his evening snacks I
don't think you could ever go wrong with
a classic PB&J Sammy it's a super easy
way to get into protein and healthy fats
and something that I definitely rely on
when I'm in a pinch one thing to be
mindful of when preparing peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches is the products
that you're using
obviously there are so many different
nut butter varieties on the market and I
don't know what brand John is
specifically using but ideally you'd
want to select a natural nut butter with
nuts as like the only ingredient without
any added salt sugar or hydrogenated
oils the same thing can be said for like
jams and jellies because a lot of them
have more sugar in them than they do
actual fruit I actually have a really
super easy low sugar chia jam on my blog
which I'm gonna leave in the description
below but if you're looking to buy one
you want to look for Polly fruit
preserves instead of jam or jelly
because fruit preserves will have more
actual fruit
lastly we don't actually see this but he
finishes his day with an Rx bar I am
personally a huge fan of these bars as
they've got basically three simple
ingredients egg whites dates and nuts I
can totally see why John would be damned
for that as an evening snack let's take
a look at day two final meal of the
night not really a meal but we have this
is just a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich it's nothing special but I
always like to have something sweet at
the end of the night so with this full
day of eating and I'm sure most of you
guys that have been falling for a while
that have watched a couple of these
videos you understand that with my
full-day meetings one I'm definitely not
saying you should try to eat exactly
like me I'm definitely not saying that
this diet is perfect for everyone what I
am showing you is what I ate today
I honestly normally eat a little bit
more today I just I guess I wasn't that
hungry and that's kind of how I live my
life is if I'm hungry I eat if I'm not I
don't and I don't really follow any sort
of plan or anything like that I just
kind of eat when I'm hungry
John aka mr. consistent talks about
ending his night off with a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich
and really I love his messaging here
around eating when he's hungry and
following his hunk accuse he admits that
he just wasn't feeling too hungry this
particular day so he didn't eat as much
as he usually would and that is
completely normal
you know our hunger levels are
influenced by so many different factors
including sleep stress level die quality
exercise medications etc so it's great
to see that John is in tune with his
body's needs and eating in a very
intuitive way without feeling
preoccupied with reaching a very
specific caloric or macro goal okay
so now let's talk about my overall
thoughts about John's what ate in a day
nutrition so not surprising for someone
who takes such good care of his body
John's meals are very balanced as most
of his meals have a nice combination of
protein carbohydrates and healthy fats
he also stays true to his word and keeps
his meals very simple and approachable
while making sure he gets the nutrition
that his body needs based on our
nutrient analysis John is getting
somewhere between 3,000 and 3700
calories about a hundred and ninety-five
grams of protein through 290 grams of
net carbs and 136 grams of fat now that
may sound like a lot but for someone
like John who works out twice a day
these amounts are actually totally
normal and healthy I will comment that
he does obviously have a tendency to
look heavily at the macro nutrient
profile of the foods he's eating and
talk about very specific portions of
some of his foods like getting a two
hundred grams of rice he also eats
pretty much the same thing every day
likely because he knows the macros and
doesn't need to count or calculate
something new this is pretty common
behavior in the fitness community and
for a lot of people this isn't
triggering at all you know the food is
fuel for their workouts and it's
enjoyable enough not to be problematic
but for others this level of
preoccupation and in flexibility can be
highly distressing so I just
a flag that John I get what you're doing
but everyone else this is not the only
way to eat and reach your goals at the
end of the day John seems to have
established a bit of a routine of eating
that is sustainable and simple to him
and is something that he actually enjoys
I also appreciate that he's self
reflected on his diet and found ways to
add more nutritive value to it by adding
more variety to his meals while also
preserving the meals that he just
consistently enjoys eating every day now
in terms of suggestions I would have
liked to maybe see a little better meal
spacing and more consistent post-workout
nourishment but I don't know if these
were just kind of like an off day or a
regular pattern for him since we don't
get a lot of insights into his daily
diet with his videos so in general is
this way of eating balanced I think
we've established that the answer to
this question is yes John's meals are
consistently well balanced with a source
of protein carbohydrate vegetables and
healthy fats his meals are even more
balanced now that he's made a commitment
to add more fruit and veggies to his
diet
so this dietician is loving that our
nutrient analysis also confirmed that
he's meeting all the necessary nutrients
for someone his age weight and activity
level which he is obviously probably
well aware of himself
are there any problematic claims or
assumptions made by this channel as I've
already mentioned John steers clear of
engaging in any sort of extreme diet
culture rules and restrictions when it
comes to food any talk of calories or
nutrition is made kind of as a means to
ensure that he has enough to satisfy his
fitness needs he even openly admits that
he doesn't care so much about calories
and repeatedly mentions that he doesn't
focus too much on what is healthy but
rather eats what he likes even if it is
repetitive based on this point of view
John appears to have a pretty good
relationship with food and a pretty
healthy mindset when it comes to food
and his body particularly in light of
his disordered eating past now even
though we don't explicitly hear john
promote
weight loss measures or problematic
behaviors it is what night in a day
videos he does bring up some
controversial topics elsewhere on his
channel namely his thoughts on the
health of every size movement and the
body positivity movement in many of his
videos he discusses his take on why haze
is dangerous as he believes it
normalizes morbid obesity and sends the
wrong message that losing weight is
impossible and people should just
therefore accept themselves as they are
now I can understand why John would see
the movement from this lens as he was
previously an obese person who was
successful at losing a significant
amount of weight and keeping it off
however I do want to flag that the vast
majority of people don't fall into this
category and we know that most people
who set out to intentionally lose weight
with restrictive dieting and up weight
cycling a.k gaining and losing weight
which can actually be more detrimental
to health than just maintaining their
original weight I will also say that a
lot of people do not have the ability in
capacity to work out two to three times
a day like John or maintain a very kind
of simplified macro focused diet having
said that the main message that John
consistently delivers on this channel
when it comes to weight loss is to do so
in a healthy and sustainable way he also
completely discourages extreme behaviors
like restrictive dieting and over
exercising as a means to reach weight
loss goals which I do appreciate him
saying in a lot of his videos he does
talk about how you can't lose weight
from a place of I hate my body and
expect those changes to last which again
I can 100% agree with I admire what John
has been able to achieve for himself
through his lifestyle changes and
appreciate the balanced messaging that
he provides for his viewers John also
does differentiate between being
overweight and being morbidly obese as
in one video he mentions that he does
believe you can be overweight and
metabolically healthy which is actually
supported by Apple scientific evidence
but he also is concerned about
glamourizing the extreme end of the
spectrum aka morbid obesity now I do
agree with John that this is murky
territory because I can appreciate the
potential health implications of being
morbidly obese well I can also
appreciate the risks of weight cycling
so I see it as a bit of a risk benefit
analysis that is really unique to the
individual I myself have had to do a lot
of research and just a lot of
soul-searching and I've shared my
updated thoughts on weight loss and haze
on my channel so you can check that out
right here if you want to know where I
stand and how I support people's goals
no matter what they are now while John
might be really vocal about denouncing
the body-positive
or fat acceptance movement and I become
a little bit more moderate or neutral in
my views at this point on this I do
appreciate that when he does discuss
influencers who promote haze or body
positivity he does so in a relatively
respective way in one video where he was
discussing Sophie Hagen's Instagram post
about celebrating world obesity day he
says that while he may not believe that
celebrating obesity as a concept is
healthy he doesn't ever judge an
individual or think negatively about the
individual rather he points out that he
doesn't really think we should be
celebrating a person for being obese the
same way that he doesn't think we should
be celebrating a person for being fit
there are just more interesting and
important attributes to a person other
than the size of pants that they wear I
also like that he says that his weight
loss didn't make him a better person
than somebody who is still 600 pounds
rather the only thing that has changed
was that he thinks he is now healthier
and that is awesome for him I mean I
agree with all of that I guess where I
get a little turned off hence why I'm
bringing this all up to you guys is that
I find he does talk about obesity and
others experiences of obesity in a less
insensitive way which again is kind of
his schtick he's all about why are we
all being so offended by everything but
as an example I've heard him say things
like eat yourself to death which yeah
seems pretty assumptive and insensitive
there isn't a whole lot of consideration
for
socioeconomic factors mental health
medication and other physical ailments
I mean his assumption is just that
someone is a size that they are solely
for eating too much and that may have
been the case for him I don't know and
it may be the case for a lot of other
people but I don't think that we can
make assumptions about why or how
someone is the size that they are so I'm
not saying that the information on his
channel is problematic per se but it may
be stigmatizing and triggering and
therefore problematic to a lot of my
viewers so that is what I'm here to flag
now are there any good takeaways from
the obesity beast channel definitely I
think we can all take something away
from his channel especially when it
comes to his philosophy around food and
keeping things simple and sustainable
this is so key when it comes to eating I
mean you can try every guy on the planet
but what it really comes down to is
whether or not you enjoy it and if it's
sustainable for you we also see John's
openness to switching up his routine and
adding more value to his way of eating I
think it can definitely be very easy for
some of us to kind of get stuck in a
routine pattern of eating so I am glad
to see that we're able to kind of take
this journey with him I'm also a big
lover of super simple food hacks and is
no fuss approach to eating and cooking
which I definitely think is a really
great takeaway for me personally bottom
line I really enjoyed John's content and
I think he's actually a really smart guy
I also enjoyed how real he is on his
channel and his no-fuss positive
attitude when it comes to food while
he's not a nutrition professional per se
he doesn't seem to promote any dangerous
fad diets and while I may not agree with
all of his statements I can fully
respect his personal experience and his
opinion well folks that is all for
today's video thank you again to audible
for sponsoring this video if you liked
it be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who you
would like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]